paul est à madame dominique nachury
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'éducation nationale
madame la ministre
hier plusieurs milliers de professeurs
étaient dans la rue manifestants contre
la réforme du collège ou pour une hausse
des salaires
votre ministère donne pour le seul
collège un taux de plus de 22% de
grévistes les enseignants du collège
avait déjà marqué par leur faible
participation ou leurs questions lors
des journées de formation à la réforme
leur désaccord avec le projet de loi
pour le collège 2016
vous êtes resté hermétique aux critiques
pourtant argumenté vous avez notamment
conduit une offensive contre l'élitisme
des classes bilangues refusant
d'entendre tous ceux qui en défendent l
intérêt pour les collégiens et pour les
collèges en volonté d'exigence et de
mixité
aujourd'hui vous présenter la nouvelle
carte des langues cette carte condamne
les classes bilangues que vous nommez de
contournement de la carte scolaire
elle maintient les classes de continuité
permettant de poursuivre une langue
autre que l'anglais débuté en primaire
notamment l'allemand vous dites madame
la ministre que 70% des classes
bilangues sont maintenues mais comment
vous croire à la lecture des chiffres
par académie paris conserve toutes ses
classes
certaines académies les préserve mieux
mais grenoble passe de 282 à soixante et
une et lyon 2 226 à 68
comment comprendre et admettre une
situation aussi contrastée vous reculez
sur le dispositif bi langues
mais dans la confusion et l'inégalité
des territoires madame la ministre vous
aviez souhaité une régulation nationales
de l'apprentissage des langues
quels résultats la parole est à madame
najat vallaud belkacem ministres
éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
les députés madame la députée nash furie
je conçois qu'il soit difficile de
comprendre la cohérence de la politique
menée par l'éducation nationale si vous
fermez vos écoutilles à chaque fois que
je voulais explique je vais reprendre
voilà des mois que de façon extrêmement
constante j'explique ce qu'est notre
stratégie pour les langues vivantes
allez on écoute en place par deux axes
stratégie la première vous plaît
remplacer des 10
si vous m'écoutez je suis sûr que vous
comprendrez le premier axe de cette
stratégie remplacer des dispositifs
dérogatoires permettant à des collégiens
d'être en classe bilangue à partir de la
classe de 6e par une mesure plus
générale permettant à tous les
collégiens d'apprendre deux langues dès
la classe de 5e
ça c'est la première chose nouvelle et
forte que nous introduisons la deuxième
stratégie importante c'est de développer
la diversité des langues vivantes
apprise à l'école primaire dans notre
pays et pour promouvoir cette diversité
à chaque fois qu'un élève apprend une
autre langue vivante que l'anglais en
école primaire
on lui permet d'accéder à l'anglais dès
la classe de 6e c'est cela que nous
appelons les bilingues de continuité
j'ai toujours dit à ce micro comme à
d'autres et depuis des mois que les
bilingues de continuité serait maintenu
ces bilans qu de continuité représenter
jusqu alors 50% de ce qu'on appelait les
bilingues dans leur ensemble
donc ne soyez pas surprise qu'à la
rentrée prochaine 50% des bilans qui
existait jusqu'à présent soit maintenue
puisque je les ai toujours dit et même
comprenez que ce chiffre va augmenter
puisque nous avons développé la
diversité des langues apprises dans le
primaire grâce à une politique proactive
nous permettant notamment d'augmenter le
nombre d'écoles primaires qui apprendre
qu'ils apprennent l'allemand en langue
vivante une 1000 nouvelles écoles
primaires qu'ils apprendront à la
rentrée prochaine
je n'ai pas entendu sur vauban vous vous
souvenez toutes ces critiques et ces
inquiétudes sur l'enseignement de
l'allemand
et bien sachez vous réjouir qu à la
rentrée prochaine nous ayons plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'enfants qui
apprennent l'allemand en plus merci
ils madame la ministre la parole est à
madame quoi